[Música]
e aí galera jornal do povo você esses
dias assisti invocação do mal eu fui 100
mil pessoas em cada fórum sei que lá e
meu patrão eu sou expert em assistir
filme terror desde que começou a era 3d
procurando dori rota gritando só que eu
tava com medo porque antes de assistir
um filme eu fui mas quando o pessoal
falar desse filme a desviar uma sessão
no cinema tal é a freira a freira
fantasma do filme apareceu no cinema
você que em brasília foi assistir à
freira está aparecendo no cinema ele
aparece na tela preparado que o ataque
só no meio da tabela mas para essa feira
apareceu está assistindo aqui de boa
chegar uma pessoa atrasada vem freire no
campus desculpa senhor foi uma desculpa
pode ser daqui você daqui a vale estando
aqui na red bull pode sair tranqüilo ido
assistir um filme sobre tal como falar
da o filme começa com aquela mulher lá
que é tipo caçador derrotada cangas
bastante e isso passa avião agora de até
um cara que é um cara que tem uma mulher
que caça fantasma casa e se perder eles
são casados 2 que esse tipo de gente só
dá certo junta não vai ver um casal de
cozinhar você faz o que é o caso do
espírito se você faz que não só da
assembléia de deus no tento olho só dá
certo com doyle estão numa casa
revivendo o negócio ali e bota a mão em
cima da mesa vamos sentir o espírito do
povo no twitter que quando a pessoa
morre ela vai pulga deixem lá pra lá não
tem que ir conectar com dispensar estão
nessa casa que tentou ser legal de
fantasma é assim que a porta abre sol e
gente se a porta abre só não é coisa de
deus e meia com que eu vou fazer quando
fui comprar a casa conferir as poema
para trás da casa carregou mais e
boquita ótima ótimas condições está tudo
no mundo melhor as telhas uma etapa está
perfeito em perfeito estado precisa ver
foi colocado agora faz abandou semana à
porta a porta de ótima qualidade ou
madeira importada que veio ela abre só
após de vez em quando o vento bate ela
abre um pouco é o cara não tá é mais
pode render outra pessoa
já no filme então os meninos com harry
sorrir sempre pelo minho todo menino
tenta lá no meio tudo conta o menino
correndo já aparece à frente na feira
rafinha só o sangue nessa área que na
gengiva cnt o dente sangue recebe a
qualquer momento apareceu um dentista
conversado a colgate dizer se isso pode
ser cheia de verde que causa o mal
alheio à procura na feira que no cinema
que o rei faz até uma certa que a
família sozinha pobrezinha na casinha
pobrezinho e tal e caminha quer brincar
com o negócio que mexe conversar com os
espíritos pra que eu não deixei pacheco
xavier becerra é pobre quer conversar
com o demônio em menino mim toda um
trabalho da apa a mim tá comendo
biscoito vai falar menino com biscoito
de noite vai da sede nem vai começar um
pouquinho que acontece o meu já do
biscoito diego foi de madrugada levando
o bebê ao me levanta vai na cozinha
cruza casa todinha no livro uma luz no
filme no rio luís batalha consigo tudo
escuro eu falar com seu voto ele no
estúdio invocam tanto que quem cantou
males espanta e ainda a música que o
cantor lhe capoeira é para espantar
mário já saber que o selo italiano não é
que mexe bem a outra irmã domingo já
começa a conversar com ela mesmo sentar
na cama de madrugada não não só é esse
favor sol não brilha e obina mas aqui eu
já não ficar delicado já mora na rua tá
nem aí não viu a irmã conversando
sozinhos e maior fazer o que não vou
dormir que é normal isso é normal essa
sozinha ano eu faço todo dia só come
bebe água de madrugada até a hora que
estava faltando algo que ele faz ele foi
uma barraquinha e perguntar ele chuta um
carrinho para dentro da barraca beleza
foi pra cama de um penso que não o carro
que ele chutou para dentro da
barraquinha começa a vir sozinho até a
beirada da cama dele aqui é que ele faz
ele grita ele corre ele tava na roupa
ele se ela todinha de bosta esse carinho
todo igual um senhor de 85 anos quando
tem mais controle das pragas do coco não
ele joga o carrinho de novo fazer da
barraca e começa a brincar com o capeta
e do nada
o diabo carrinho de mim sai gritando de
bombeiro e um susto da [__] eo pior que
trilha sonora de filme o que deixa tudo
comigo que fica todo mundo olhando assim
ao esbarrar na cabeça
o que tinha sonora é assim que no quadro
de amares modo mais no filme trilha
sonora boto mostrar bota bota o sus bota
da mari
até agora caminha assistir televisão do
nada a ver um cara amor detrás da
televisão e fala assim minha casa fosse
comigo eu conversava com outro dia meu
patrão essa é só a casa pode ficar com
ela para não ficar brigando por água de
casa para besteira mas a casa toda hora
aparece um morro a pessoa que morou na
casa disse que a casa dela fica que só
aparece de madrugada é que o espírito
que tem munhos só quer conversar com as
pessoas de madrugada só chega nacional
que o demônio de que o japão que não vê
na hora do almoço sempre como uma pessoa
na mesa explica rapaz a casa é minha
cara e eu morri e ficam as pendências e
os parada eu voltei pra consertar no
broto aí não tem que aparecer de
madrugada estava a dormir né diz ainda
que eu morri mas essa melhoria é uma
cena que a frenagem de 20 começa a
caminhar pela casa dos caras que caça
fantasma que a caminhada começará o
cinema que inventou nada fosse buscam
parceria com a família a minha pobre
vida perturbada com o satanás na carga
do sin sai de casa o pessoal vai lá pra
casa dos outros atletas
a peta na casa do jogo é este é uma
mulher que caça fantasma eu quero que
caça fantasma para poder resolver o
problema deles nessa hora o seguinte tem
uma casa né o que tranqüilo do nada
começou a aparecer os negócios demônio a
cama da minha frente do negócio de
hidromassagem que começou a treinar
minha cama ea partir de moldes em que a
casa é dele que imaginação e recebendo
visita em casa rui costa tinha tudo bem
mulher como é que estava aumentando toda
molhada que estava no bolso ele vai
entrando bem no reparo do demônio e não
é para lavar o funcionário demônio aí a
família que caça fantasma começa a fazer
um teste na casa para ver se a de
movimento e fazer o teste e voltava pra
sentar na cadeira que o velho morreu
descobrir o que o velho morreu na
cadeira que ela gosta de sentar nela se
mexer só votaria cinema decadente e mexe
só também gosta porta que abre só
cadeira de balanço que se mexe só agora
começa a conversar com o espírito da
casa que essa normalmente banda interage
niassa e precisa de união resolveu
chamar o próximo mas não tá me matar
próximo dali na casa no hospital e
conversa com ele interação eu assistindo
aqui no cinema pessoa que não olhou não
é só a cabeça e méxico venceu na outra
pessoa casada chegando não pode pegar se
deve tomar no topo foi levada até a hora
do filme que o espírito se manifesta da
menina ea cadeira voando
mesmo até mesmo na cadeira bate na minha
gente correr pular boca é branco tudo
rebentando que é branco para essa roda
punk todo mundo gritando aparece o diabo
da freira no canto do quarto mas o que é
que o espírito só parece encanto é
espírita e mexa até parecer fornos
cantava aproveitado aqui é pra ele
sequer dei pra cá está
por isso quando eu fizer vou fazer toda
redonda que pude aparecer em canto
nenhum se você tiver gostar desse vídeo
não se esquece de clicar aqui embaixo no
youtube em gostei taco pessoal às vezes
esquece acabando vídeo a festa nem que
gostei até ajudei bota lá no facebook ou
porque se tivesse um vídeo novo
colocação do mouse e que se aplica a
encurte e marca seus amigos comentário
assim o que mascara que assiste vocação
do mal olha que ele falando dizer o que
quer e tem gente que tem mesmo assistir
o filme pois assisti aqui não tem medo e
se inscreve no canal falou que perdeu um
vídeo novo é nóis estão chegando a 10
milhões em galera queria pedir desculpa
você que eu demoro a gravar com minha
câmera quebrou e essa daqui é esse que
eu tô aqui é meu celular gravando
celular tá não fica assim valeu é isso
aí valeu galera e branquinho e olha só
eu estou fazendo vários shows aparecer
na tela do gmail já olha se você quiser
comprar ingressos para um dos shows
esse link está aparecendo aqui embaixo
valeu